thank you yes sir and I have ler with me
today ler just finished your game in the
draw but first of all like what approach
did you have today while you were doing
the opening choice I mean such an
important game for you yeah well I uh it
was very simple just to play normal what
I intended to play anyway so in terms of
the opening I didn't really consider
going uh crazy or or anything like that
I was just trying to play a good game
and um yeah I guess uh not much was
going on very solid game
yeah so um actually like can you please
describe let's say what happened with
wor simply like uh position was kind of
equal yes from the beginning yeah it's
it's a very solid line I mean black has
a such a sound position that you can
generally speak and play uh um almost
what you want of course uh White is
always having a slight initiative but um
I I don't think I had any any troll uh
he he at some point he went for this
Knight D2 Knight F1 IDE M yeah and and
then yeah white gets D4 Knight D6 Knight
G3 B5
F3 and yeah and I was playing for D5 so
Rook a d8 d takes C5 I guess I could
take with a pawn here if this is also
pretty solid I mean queen D7 and then
for example Knight D7 also some kind of
end game I thought maybe he can hope for
something but uh yeah again black is
very very solid so I decided to play
uh more concrete 95 aiming for the D6 D5
break and then then it was a bit more
here uh more concrete uh of course
Bishop main idea is that after D5 white
takes on E5 and then plays F4 E5 and
gets some some
Advantage um that's why I play the move
C5 uh Knight G6 was possible too but
then Bishop E3 D5 Bishop D4 and here I
wasn't sure I was calculating something
like um because if D4 Bishop F6
obviously and after Queen C6 I thought
E5 Knight D7 and Knight H5 and it's very
tricky because now E6 is coming and F4
as well and if I take on E5 there is F4
and G7 fall so this kind of ideas um uh
he was trying to to trick you somewhere
actually to trick me somewhere but the
position is so solid I mean that it's
it's very hard to so I think C5 is a
good move just deny the bishop to D4
Square just gring some space in the
center like this I can play Queen C6
sometimes sometimes immediately D5 and
then after Queen D2 D5 I think uh yeah
it was this line was I guess critical
but it didn't look uh good because I
have Rook E6 and then after Knight F5
Knight E8 protect G7 he can play Queen
G5 here because Knight G6 uh I mean Rook
G6 uh Knight D7 but uh after King f8 I
thought uh position should be fine for
black and and it's also a bit risky
because um after all um it's a piece
yeah so something like this I was I
would be very happy to get because I I
would even get chances to play for a win
but uh yeah after after Bishop takes E5
and and Rook A1 uh then a draw it's
pretty much uh inevitable yeah and uh
did you were you following also the game
of Fabby at this same time while you
were playing yours or you Tred to
concentrate on only on yours yeah no not
I would say not much difference let's
say if we compare with the previous
round I'm always interested in in the
rest of the games but not especially I
mean I know it's going to be um a tough
game I mean richer is a although he's
not having the best tournament he's
still a very strong player and he's
capable of um of winning against anyone
so it's it's a tough game in general and
um let's have a quick look see what's
going on what do you think about
position yeah looks uh unclear to me
seems that black is doing fun fine but
white is also maybe doing fine so I
guess I guess yeah it's it's pretty even
yeah yeah so now it's interesting
situation like if Fabby makes a draw
then you have to play this playoff like
what's your plan now what are you going
to do yeah well first of all I mean um
it was a good tournament for me no
matter what so plus two undefeated in
this field it's great so congratulations
actually yes it was really good event um
yeah I couldn't ask for more so uh but I
still have chances so if if if I
eventually get a chance to to play for
for the for the first place in the
playoff I'll I'll try to to do my best
and to use my chances yeah and now also
this all the situation with the
candidate Sport and uh today was also
this clarification from F about the
rules what do you think about it and
yeah well actually I had little time for
for all this also it was a bit
surprising as I told you yesterday I
wasn't um I mean I was aware of vaguely
of the idea but uh uh I didn't expect it
to be so close and um and yeah so I I
had time to to check what the uh the
statement put forward by FID and I saw
then uh some comments Chris for example
was commenting that uh uh this wasn't in
the original rule so if that's the case
that's of course not great from F but I
I mean again I plan to kind of after the
tournament I you will think about it
I'll think about all this and and see
what uh what what should I do if you're
only chances to play some events outside
of us are you going to do so probably
yes yes because it's uh I mean it's a
it's a nice chance I mean it's not so I
mean it's not every day obviously that
you get a chance to to fight for for a
place in the candidate so yeah I I would
do it that's great great news we still
don't know what will happen afterwards
let's wait for the game of Fabby to to
finish and thank you so much ler for all
your comments and congratulations once
again it was a great event thank you
thank you thank you Anastasia yeah and
we would like to add our congratulations
also to lir